en mi más digamos humilde opinión la
reacción bioquímica más importante
especialmente para nosotros es la
respiración celular que vamos a notar
esto es la respiración celular y la
razón por la cual digamos me siento muy
seguro de esto es porque es digamos la
forma en la que obtenemos energía a
partir de lo que comemos digamos de
nuestro combustible verdad o si queremos
ser un poco más específicos obtenemos la
energía de la glucosa y al final del día
digamos la mayor parte de lo que comemos
o al menos todos los carbohidratos
verdad terminan como glucosa y en vídeos
futuros voy a hablar de cómo obtenemos
esta energía por ejemplo también de
grasas o de proteínas pero la la
respiración celular digamos no nos
permite o digamos ir de la glucosa de la
glucosa y a partir de la glucosa obtener
energía
no tenemos energía a partir de la
glucosa y por supuesto también tenemos
otros subproductos verdad y para hacer
un poquito más específico es verdad
déjenme escribir la reacción química
aquí tendremos la reacción química por
ejemplo martín vamos a partir de la
fórmula química de la glucosa que es c6
verdad es decir tenemos 6 átomos de
carbono h 12 que son 12 átomos de
hidrógeno y 6 átomos de oxígeno entonces
tenemos 6 h 12 o 6 esto de aquí es
justamente la glucosa esto es la glucosa
y además hay que agregar digamos 6 moles
verdad si tenemos aquí un molde glucosa
hay que agregar 6 moles de oxígeno
gaseoso y digamos como una digamos una
simplificación muy grande que hacemos a
todo el proceso de la respiración
celular de hecho vamos a observar en los
próximos vídeos que uno puede
complicarse en estos procesos en este
mecanismo tan complicado
se puede no complicar tanto como sea
posible verdad y digamos al menos a
grandes rasgos verdad
digamos podemos simplificar este proceso
simplemente como si tuviéramos un molde
glucosa 6 moles de oxígeno gaseoso
verdad y obtenemos a través de la
respiración celular de este proceso de
la respiración celular y lo voy a
escribir aquí aquí vamos a digamos a
basarnos
la respiración celular es un mecanismo y
a partir de este mecanismo obtenemos lo
siguiente obtenemos 6 moles de dióxido
de carbono y obtenemos 6 moles de agua
verdad pero no sólo eso digamos esta es
una parte importante pero yo creo que la
parte más importante aquí es que
producimos energía entonces vamos a
tener energía producida y de hecho esta
es la energía que puede ser utilizada
para digamos hacer cierto tipo de
trabajos como calentar nuestros cuerpos
o digamos generar impulsos eléctricos en
nuestro cerebro así digamos nos nos
brinda energía del mecanismo de la
respiración celular nos brinda energía
especialmente para todas las necesidades
de un cuerpo humano y por supuesto esto
no es únicamente para humanos verdad
también puede ser para otro tipo de
organismos muy bien y cuando decimos
energía verdad cuando estamos hablando
de la energía tú podrías decir oye
en otro vídeo que no que no simplemente
dijiste que el atp es la digamos la
moneda energética de la célula y
entonces nosotros decíamos que el atp es
la moneda energética de los sistemas
biológicos verdad
y entonces tú podrías decir oye parece
ser entonces que más bien la glucosa es
nuestra moneda digamos energética verdad
y hasta cierto punto las dos respuestas
serían correctas pero pero para ver un
poquito de cómo es que en realidad
digamos las dos respuestas pueden ser
correctas digamos el proceso de la
respiración celular si produce energía
directamente pero esta energía esta
energía que estamos produciendo en esta
reacción química se utiliza para
producir dos cosas por un lado vamos a
producir calor y por otro lado vamos a
producir 38
es 38 atp o al menos eso es lo que
digamos varios libros de texto dicen
verdad los libros de texto dicen que se
producen 38 atp y digamos pueden ser
utilizados por las células para digamos
contraer músculos o generar impulsos
nerviosos o hacer lo que sea necesario
digamos crecer dividirse o cualquier
otra necesidad de la célula así que
realmente la respiración celular verdad
decimos que produce energía pero esto
digamos así nada más no es del todo
cierto verdad en realidad es el proceso
que toma digamos mediante el cual toma
glucosa verdad y produce atp se produce
atp y quizás con algo de calor y algunos
subproductos verdad todo esto esto no es
del todo malo verdad digamos es bueno
obtener calor alrededor digamos
necesitamos estar razonablemente
calientito es verdad para que nuestras
células puedan operar correctamente así
que todo el punto digamos de este
mecanismo es ir de la glucosa
ir de la glucosa obtener nuestros atp es
que según los libros de texto son 38 atp
porque entonces esta energía podríamos
también pensarla como nuestros nuestros
38 atp es verdad en esencia por cada
molécula de glucosa vamos a obtener 38
moléculas de atp y eso es lo que dicen
los libros de texto ahora en realidad
esto es digamos en circunstancias
ideales que vamos a producir 38 atp yo
estaba leyendo un poco antes de hacer
este vídeo y en realidad depende de la
eficiencia de la célula verdad para
poder realizar la respiración celular
pero probablemente sea más bien del
orden de entre 29 y 30 atp hay una gran
variación aquí pero bueno digamos las
digamos los científicos todavía están
estudiando esta idea pero en esencia
todo esto de la respiración celular se
trata de convertir una molécula de
glucosa y obtener 38 atp es verdad ahora
en los próximos vídeos vamos a
digamos separando todas estas ideas todo
este mecanismo en sus partes que lo
constituyen verdad y voy a presentarte
todas estas partes de este mecanismo
verdad para que te des una mejor idea de
cómo funciona toda la respiración
celular pero vamos a ir mencionando
algunas algunas de estas partes la
primera de ellas es la glucólisis muy
bien voy a anotarlo aquí la primera
parte es la glucólisis
la glucólisis muy bien y que
literalmente significa digamos cómo
separar la la glucosa muy bien así que
por ejemplo esta parte la parte gluco
verdad de la palabra glucólisis
significa glucosa se refiere a la
glucosa mientras que lee si es verdad la
parte lisis significa digamos como como
romper o separar cuando hablábamos de la
hidrólisis significaba utilizar agua
para romper una molécula la glucólisis
significa que vamos a estar rompiendo
digamos la glucosa o separando la
glucosa y digamos en el caso de que te
interesa en el origen de las palabras
verdad la etimología la palabra glucosa
voy a descomponer la aquí verdad
la palabra glucosa en realidad proviene
en parte de una palabra griega verdad
esta parte glup glup verdad significa o
más bien proviene de una palabra griega
que se refiere a lo dulce
a luz dulce mientras que la terminación
osa es la que le damos siempre a todas a
todos los azúcares verdad entonces esta
de aquí es la terminación que le damos
por ser un azúcar y uno pensaría que
quizás es un poco redundante decir que
hay azúcares dulces verdad pero en
realidad puede también haber digamos
azúcares que no son dulces por ejemplo
la lactosa que es la que se encuentra en
la leche puede ser un poco dulce pero
cuando de hecho digerimos la lactosa la
convertimos en una en un azúcar que en
realidad si es luz dulce pero pero no
necesariamente de inicio tienen que
saber dulces verdad como por ejemplo la
glucosa o la fructosa
pero bueno eso fue sólo un paréntesis
verdad el primer paso de la respiración
celular es la glucólisis muy bien que sé
qué significa o que implica que vamos a
separar oa romper la glucosa y ahora
déjame mostrarte cómo es que se ve
realmente la glucosa
tengo arriba una imagen de lo que es la
glucosa y podemos ver que en efecto
tiene 6 átomos de carbono verdad aquí
tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 átomos de carbono y
podemos observar que en realidad tiene
como una especie de estructura de anillo
verdad así que tenemos nuestros 6 átomos
de carbono podemos observar que hay 6
átomos de oxígeno 1 2 3 4 5 6 y luego
estas pelotitas azules verdad en
realidad son nuestros hidrógenos muy
bien esos son nuestros hidrógenos y así
es como se ve en realidad la glucosa
pero este proceso de la glucólisis
verdad déjenme regresar aquí abajo el
proceso de la glucólisis digamos y
empezamos con nuestra cadena voy a
ponerlo como una cadena verdad
digamos tenemos nuestra cadena de 6
átomos de carbono verdad y esto lo hago
para fines de lo que quiero explicar ya
vimos que en realidad se ve más bien
como una especie de anillo verdad tiene
de hecho también algunos
hidrógeno si algunos oxígenos hay unidos
a esta cadena verdad pero esencialmente
tiene como esta columna principal de
carbonos y lo que vamos a hacer es
separar esa columna de carbonos en dos
verdad vamos a separarlo en dos partes
en dos partes que tienen tres carbonos
cada uno y recordemos que por supuesto
aquí también hay otros átomos unidos no
sé de hidrógenos oxígenos pero en
esencia hemos separado esta columna
principal de carbonos en otras dos
digamos en otras dos partes con tres
carbonos cada uno verdad y los digamos
otras cosas que están unidas ahora cada
una de estas moléculas que tienen tres
átomos de carbono se les conoce como
piruvato y vamos a entrar en más detalle
sobre los piratas y este proceso en otro
vídeo pero la glucólisis digamos por sí
misma genera bueno quizás deberíamos
anotarlo de esta forma la glucólisis en
realidad necesita
se citan dos a tps para poder llevarse a
cabo 2 atp y además genera genera 4 atp
es entonces si nosotros hacemos el
balance neto verdad si hacemos el
balance podemos observar que tenemos 2
atp en total que tenemos 2 atp y esta es
la primera etapa de la respiración
celular verdad y lo importante que
podemos mencionar aquí es que esto puede
ocurrir en ausencia de oxígeno este
proceso no requiere de oxígeno y como ya
te lo mencioné haré todo un vídeo sobre
la glucólisis en un futuro estos
subproductos que tenemos por aquí verdad
en realidad se modifican un poquito y
después entran algo que conocemos como
el ciclo de krebs aquí van a entrar a
algo conocido como el ciclo de krebs y
quizás debería utilizar otro color
utilizar amarillo estos subproductos
entran al ciclo de krebs que es otro
mecanismo verdad y este mecanismo por si
mismo podríamos pensar que produce 2 atp
es muy bien produce 2 atp es por su
cuenta y esto es digamos algo
interesante verdad porque también hay
otro proceso que podríamos decir que
ocurre después del ciclo de krebs aunque
sabemos que en la célula todo está
rebotando y todo está digamos
difundiéndose en la célula verdad pero
bueno se considera que esto ocurre
después de la glucólisis y del ciclo de
krebs y algo que hay que mencionar antes
de pasar al siguiente paso es que el
ciclo de krebs si requiere oxígeno sirve
si requiere oxígeno muy bien este ciclo
de krebs requiere oxígeno y solo para
ser claros en realidad la glucólisis
este primer proceso proceso digamos no
requiere oxígeno no se necesita el
oxígeno y de hecho vamos a notarlo
la glucólisis no necesita oxígeno
mientras que el ciclo de krebs si
requiere del oxígeno verdad o podríamos
pensar que la glucólisis por no
necesitar oxígeno es un proceso
anaerobio y quizás deberíamos ser más
ordenados en esta parte vamos a notarlo
de esta forma nosotros tenemos la
glucólisis aquí tenemos la glucólisis
verdad este es un proceso que es
anaerobio
obvio es decir no requiere de oxígeno
para poder llevarse a cabo verdad y
quizás seas estés familiarizado con la
idea del ejercicio anaeróbico verdad que
significa aerobio verdad qué significa
esta parte la idea por ejemplo del
ejercicio aeróbico es que necesita
respirar muy fuerte verdad porque
necesitas mucho oxígeno para hacer
ejercicio aeróbico así que cuando
estamos hablando de un proceso anaerobio
verdad significa que no necesitamos
oxígeno aeróbico significa que necesita
oxígeno anaeróbico significa lo
contrario que no requiere del oxígeno
así que la glucólisis es un proceso
anaerobio y también parte importante es
que produce 2 atp
en total verdad en total
muy bien tenemos una producción de 2 atp
en total y luego si nos vamos por
ejemplo al ciclo de krebs el ciclo de
krebs sería como nuestro siguiente paso
verdad el ciclo de krebs ciclo de krebs
voy a escribirlo mejor el ciclo de
crepes
y lo tenemos este sí es un proceso
aerobio
es obvio y también tenemos una
producción de 2 atp es muy bien tenemos
una producción de 2 atp por supuesto
entre la glucólisis y el ciclo de krebs
hay un digamos breve preámbulo aquí pero
vamos a entrar en detalle digamos de
este punto en el futuro si lo importante
aquí es que el ciclo de krebs es aerobio
y tiene 2 atp y luego del ciclo de krebs
hay una parte que francamente cuando yo
lo aprendí por vez primera verdad en
realidad esto me confundió muchísimo
pero bueno solo vamos a ponerlo en el
orden en el que tradicionalmente este
escrito verdad después del ciclo de
krebs tenemos algo que se le conoce como
el digamos la cadena de transporte de
electrones es la cadena
y transporte de electrones
de electrones muy bien y esta parte es
muy importante porque con la cadena de
transporte de electrones tenemos la
formación de 34 atp es que si podemos
darnos cuenta es como la mayor
producción de atp es que vamos a tener
en todo el proceso de la respiración
celular y esto es importante porque
también es un proceso aerobio muy bien
requiere también de oxígeno para
llevarse a cabo así que como podemos ver
si no tuviéramos oxígeno si las células
no estuvieran obteniendo suficiente
oxígeno podríamos podríamos producir un
poquito de energía verdad aquí podríamos
producir un poquito de energía por estos
2 atp de la glucólisis verdad pero una
vez que ya tenemos suficiente oxígeno
verdad podríamos empezar a producir más
atp es verdad y se debe al ciclo de
krebs y a la cadena de transporte d
electrones muy bien ahora cuando nos
empezamos a quedar sin oxígeno verdad
entonces todo este procedimiento no
puede llevarse a cabo de forma adecuada
y lo que ocurre es que algunos de estos
subproductos de la glucólisis verdad en
vez de entrar al ciclo de krebs entran a
un proceso paralelo llamado fermentación
así que lo voy a escribir por acá entra
en un proceso llamado fermentación
bien está muy bien para algunos
organismos este proceso de fermentación
toma algunos de los subproductos de la
glucólisis y literalmente producen por
ejemplo alcohol verdad al día de hecho
parte del alcohol que la gente consume
viene de ahí y se le conoce a esto como
la fermentación alcohólica para nosotros
digamos como seres humanos nosotros no
producimos alcohol sino por ejemplo
nuestros músculos no producen el alcohol
en realidad lo que producen es el ácido
láctico que voy a ponerlo nosotros como
seres humanos producimos ácido láctico
muy bien y esto por supuesto es porque
somos humanos ok en otros organismos
puede haber otro tipo de producción es
verdad por ejemplo esto quizás sea
válido para también otro tipo de
mamíferos pero por ejemplo también
tenemos la levadura verdad la levadura
es lo que se utiliza para producir
cierto tipo por ejemplo de pan y lo que
ocurre es que
hay una fermentación alcohólica es decir
la levadura produce al alcohol
fermentación alcohólica
muy bien pero bueno todo este proceso de
la fermentación es justamente cuando no
disponemos de el oxígeno necesario
verdad y de hecho es el ácido láctico el
que por ejemplo cuando hacemos mucho
ejercicio verdad y no obtenemos
suficiente oxígeno entonces nuestros
músculos se empiezan a doler y eso es
porque se empieza a formar el ácido
láctico pero bueno toda esta es una
cuestión paralela verdad sí sí digamos
tuviéramos suficiente oxígeno entonces
podemos movernos al ciclo de krebs que
es un proceso aerobio verdad obtenemos
nuestros 2 atp y luego pasamos a la
cadena de transporte de electrones y
producimos nuestros 34 atp es muy bien
que en realidad es la mayor producción
de atp es que va a ocurrir en la
respiración celular
vamos a digamos mencionar esto como de
forma paralela pero pero mientras estos
dos procesos se llevan a cabo la
glucólisis y el ciclo de krebs y verdad
también se van a producir otro tipo de
moléculas y en estas dos partes de en
estas dos reacciones digamos la
glucólisis y el ciclo de krebs verdad en
estos dos justamente vamos a estar
tomando constantemente una molécula que
se llama enea de simplemente lo voy a
llamar como nada verdad en realidad es
nada más
y vamos a añadir hidrógenos para formar
lo que conocemos como una h
muy bien
y lo que realmente ocurre es digamos por
cada molécula de glucosa 10 nada verdad
10 de estos nada se convierten en nada
es muy bien así que en realidad estos
son en gran parte los que impulsan la
cadena de transporte de electrones y
vamos a hablar más a detalle de cómo es
que esto ocurre y cómo es que de ahí se
obtiene energía y cómo es que esta es
una reacción de oxidación vamos a hablar
de qué es lo que se está oxidando qué es
lo que se está reduciendo pero sí quería
mencionarlo estos dos procesos verdad no
sólo no sólo están produciendo sus 2 atp
es en cada uno de estos en cada una de
estas etapas verdad sino que también
están produciendo verdad de forma
combinada 10 nada h es verdad y digamos
que además cada uno de ellos produce atp
digamos 3 atp es en una situación ideal
ahora bien por otro lado también están
haciendo algo similar a otra molécula
verdad que es
fíjate que de hecho es bastante similar
verdad y lo que ocurre aquí es que está
produciéndose faz h2 muy bien es algo
digamos de un proceso bastante similar
verdad ahora yo sé que todo esto es
bastante complicado pero vamos a hacer
vídeos de esto en el futuro lo
importante digamos aquí es recordar que
la respiración celular consiste
principalmente en tomar glucosa verdad y
digamos la energía que está en la
glucosa y re empaquetarla en forma de lo
que sabemos que dicen los libros de
texto que son 38 atp muy bien así que si
estás haciendo un examen es un muy buen
número para escribirlo verdad en el
examen y en realidad tiende a ser un
número mucho más pequeño verdad como del
orden de 30 atp es verdad y por supuesto
también va a producir calor de hecho
gran parte de estas reacciones van a
producir calor pero
los 38 atp que estamos generando en
realidad se generan a lo largo de tres
etapas verdad que hemos puesto aquí
abajo la primera de ellas es la
glucólisis que en donde estamos
partiendo a la glucosa en dos verdad y
generamos atp pero digamos también parte
importante de esto es que estamos
generando algunos nada es verdad que
serán utilizados después en la cadena de
transporte de electrones verdad luego
estos subproductos digamos se van a
separar más y esto será en el ciclo de
krebs verdad que también va a producir 2
atp es verdad y también va a producir
varios nada es verdad y todos esos
nadies van a ser utilizados en la cadena
de transporte de electrones verdad para
producir la mayor parte de nuestra
moneda energética que son 34 atp